all right get that [ __ ] down
what's happening the church of what's
happening now wednesday
may 28th we ain't got time for [ __ ]
[ __ ] around today because it's that
type of day it's wednesday you know i'm
saying people like joey it's wednesday
so who gives a [ __ ] it's wednesday
monday you were thinking about hot dogs
yesterday you were still [ __ ] half
[ __ ] from the hot dog juice today
you're back you had a three day [ __ ]
week pick yourself up get it together i
know you're feeling blue i don't feel
like get the [ __ ] up who gives a [ __ ]
what you feel life ain't waiting for
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ]
what's up my little brother nothing you
every time i see you more of those
things i got [ __ ] tubes from
everywhere i can't just throw them away
you gotta
this one's no good
i gotta get a new [ __ ] batch what's
up with you nothing how are you feeling
i feel great i'm always excited for for
tonight you're always excited for
tonight but it's just uh i've been
running i don't know what it is
usually when i look for an apartment i
get the first one i want
i keep getting [ __ ] blocked now so it's
been kind of a frustrating month but
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do you got a pad you're not hitting the
car no more you're back i never hit it
but it just somebody [ __ ] hit it
toxic
you should see it this dude it's it's
it's an extra audi he's letting his
girlfriend drive it and she's just not
telling him or something so they thought
they could get one over on on the jew
but the jew don't [ __ ] around [ __ ]
so what are you going to do
how about i hit in the head with this
vaping tube got something gonna do that
anyways [ __ ] smoke if people listen
to our conversations half of it is don't
make me come over there and kick you in
the shin 18 times with a steel toed boot
let me open it in the head with the
e-cigarette and with a dog [ __ ] on your
head
it's a beautiful day to be alive get up
may 28th memorial day week the beginning
of the summer is really june 21st but
[ __ ] that's what they say
thank you very much for listening uh to
sunday night special day keep hitting
that [ __ ] lee it's wednesday
[ __ ] you gotta shake el diablo
the sarah tiana podcast we thought it
was something different we always like
doing something different don't have to
be jumping up and down i want to get a
little woman's love in the office a
little woman's perspective i want to
thank her for coming on i also want to
congratulate nailed in life david alonso
and pete i love you guys up there you
guys do a great job with the vapor pen
and
los gumis and mano for welcoming a new
family member
a new [ __ ] cuban that's what we need
the world needs another [ __ ] cuban
you know what i'm saying
the world needs another cuban like
[ __ ] julie you're following me we
don't need no more [ __ ] jews and no
more [ __ ] cubans we gotta trim the
hurt on the jews we got rebuilt no we
got to rebuild again
there's a lot of work this [ __ ]
is walking around with sandals
looking around let's go home and let's
go home and play ping pong i gotta stay
we got to get the jews back to the day
one what are you one jews doing out
there suing people looking for homes
making opportunities [ __ ] you know
people telling people they can't bring
black people to games you know
jews forget who the [ __ ] they are with
this new like everybody else in the
society they forget who the [ __ ] they
are you should try to get them on the
show they want to be who a mean jew yeah
the woman would sterling we should get
sterling on the show [ __ ] that old man
he's probably pissed i love to get
sterling on the show listen to him back
pedal
he loves black people no no what you
would do is you would you would just
start like saying like agreeing with
them and get them going
like give them like two of these and
just get them going
i hate [ __ ] black people they got dry
feet you know the whole [ __ ] thing
you know just getting hindus too [ __ ]
everybody
leave mother [ __ ] say out what's
happening brother
you walked yesterday yeah no i'm trying
and it's just
i'm trying to decide or
i honestly don't know what i'm waiting
for you ever when you started losing
weight did you ever have that moment
where like i'm trying to like part of me
like maybe i should get a bike maybe i
should join the gym and i just i don't i
should just do it and break down but
it's what do you like
biking i like that a lot because so
you're gonna get a bike and drive around
[ __ ] hollywood that's what you tell
them
we're gonna put a helmet on you like
yeah those [ __ ] scoots they have that
what i've been thinking about is they
have that path on chandler you're not
gonna do it so forget about it you think
i have i i [ __ ] if i put a pork chop out
for you and said walk over here i got a
pork chop for you yeah you wouldn't walk
so forget about that's getting the bike
and getting the bike and putting the
helmet on and going to chandler
hopefully it's a nice day you know
there's so many variables and that's why
i tell you to walk yeah you want to
start with the most easiest common
denominator i like these people that
well i joined this gym in pasadena wait
a second you have a hard time going to
[ __ ] routes to go shopping yeah well
they gave me a deal i'm telling you
that's an hour there and an hour back
you're not gonna make it happen it's
three hours you need something at first
it's easy that's why i get the
kettlebells i don't move my car because
they're in the trunk of my car so i go
down there
and if i get in the [ __ ] mess
when i first wanted to lose weight when
i was
the first time was after the longest
yard and i went across the street and i
was totally out of shape i was smoking
three packs of cigarettes a day three
packs yeah i was doing two and probably
one or two packs when i got coke oh my
god i would get another two packs of
camels they used to come with a
promotional if you buy one you can go oh
yeah
i would smoke every [ __ ] cigarette
that's when i go to bed
guys you have no [ __ ] idea if i go
back to 2005 you have no
[ __ ] idea what i was doing on a
monday night you figure
okay my week consists of seven days okay
okay like everybody else my main goal
every day is to write one hour a day i
know i'm my schedules this is monday
tuesday wednesday thursday first thing
you see is right one out would they okay
like for today you would see write one
hour and then you'd see
podcasts at six am and then you see
audition at four and live podcast at
eight okay okay
i didn't have a schedule back then
i didn't even have a notebook i would
just get up and my days were acapella if
i wrote comedy i wrote conley if i
didn't write i didn't write comedy i
made notes with a notebook but it wasn't
it wasn't that it was how i was it was
how i was living i was getting up eating
breakfast and then eating another
breakfast out
i was doing everything to avoid working
out yeah you would call me and say hey
joey let's go eat lunch
i can't work out me and lee going to
talk about the podcast you know i made i
gave myself excuses and listen man
that's everybody we all give ourselves
excuses
like i said i treated that ymca i moved
with him with terry in 2000
and until 2005. it took me five years
you know what the honda dealer is yeah
that was where the y was yeah you showed
me yeah i showed you
i wouldn't cross the street lee
i thought the devil lived there i made
you know there was battered women were
there that's why i said
there's battered women it's not a gym i
would tell myself that finally
you go to events i would go with rogue
and these young guys
and i couldn't even walk from the
[ __ ] airport i remember tate fletcher
carrying my luggage and picking me up
not lying to you people here i'm not
kidding you people these were my friends
rogan would park the car far away so i
would have to walk i would be pissed at
him
because it was a nightmare i would go to
hotels and sit in the room the whole
time they would work out they would go
swimming i would meet them to go in the
pool and i would do a couple laps and i
always had my own workout they would go
come with us no no i'm gonna do my own
workout my workout was sitting in my
room and stretching that was it these
guys were offering me my help i had
eddie bravo joe rogan tate
ahri they're all going come downstairs
we'll teach you jiu jitsu no no no no no
and i just avoided it because i was
embarrassed
my body the shape i was in i remember
brody stevens used to go joey diaz has
the body of a 50 year old man when i was
32 years old
i was just out of [ __ ] breath you
know between the cigarettes the blow the
[ __ ] weed you know it just took its
toll but my whole thing was food
i love [ __ ] food man we all love food
yeah but it wasn't love for food it was
just gluttony yeah you mean uh you're
never happy after you do it like you
don't feel full no because you didn't do
[ __ ] you didn't do [ __ ] it was it was
and i'm not kidding you i would make my
wife make breakfast let's make breakfast
all you need to do is give my wife a
green light
especially to fry she'll fry anything
out of new york [ __ ] minute she's
from the south bro
don't fry [ __ ] anything bread
those [ __ ] people fry beans they'll
fry anything i talked to the father
yesterday was frying up kyle something
they fry up [ __ ] okay so she would fry
up i'd say three eggs i'd get a whole
loaf of wonder bread and get a tub of
butter and just put it on the white
bread and get the egg yolk and put it on
the bread and eat it and i would eat
three of those eggs
we'd kill a pack of bacon
jesus and a half a loaf of bread and
three cans of coke
oh my god and then i would wait now i'd
get high again and then i go to
mcdonald's before 11
and get the egg mcmuffin the potato and
the coke again
i remember one night the bartender
at the [ __ ] comedy store said you
drank like [ __ ] 10 cokes tonight
one time at the miami improv the owner
of the club came over to me he goes you
drank 16 cokes tonight from the bar like
like 16 [ __ ] cokes at night
you know there was no water in my life
then i wouldn't even consider drinking
[ __ ] water water was beneath me
yeah and it's just this pattern you get
into you just that's and it's an
avoidance and this to a point where
you're putting clothes on they don't fit
no more
you feel like [ __ ] when you go to get up
you feel like [ __ ] it's just this whole
continuing down spiral it sucks you in
and then you know most of america does
not understand they don't even know
where to start right
america listen we don't know where to
start
we do we all do like i was talking to
rick the other night like you've said it
before like i know if i wanted to lose
weight i should eat salads and i should
work out i should it's just
for me it's a or the pattern is i've
never done it and then so it seems scary
and then it just it's so much easier not
to do it like that's no it's not because
it carries over into your hole it does
ever since i started
doing this it catches on
you catch on and nothing happens in one
day
nothing rome was not built in a day you
have an extra 100 pounds on your body
you didn't just put it on overnight
right you just didn't wake up so it's
going to take time and that's the killer
climb is the killer
with everything in our lives yeah i
almost got tricked again and i i have to
stop myself from ordering and
i don't even watch it but have you seen
pawn stars like the the guys in vegas
doing that pawn shop yeah yeah
apparently one of them was really big
and he lost a lot of weight and men's
health had this whole thing i saw on
facebook he took this pill for three
months and lost 70 pounds still working
out and part of me was like they found
it but i
found nothing yeah i found nothing
because
everything is a shortcut in america we
all know shortcuts don't work we all
know as human beings that shortcuts
don't work after a while after you're
like 20 something you go wow they don't
[ __ ] work okay none of that [ __ ]
works what i'm gonna do and what weight
watchers taught me
before dolce before anybody that's why
i'm so loyal to weight watchers it was
weight watchers and it was rick and i
who walked into weight watchers
and rick and i it works
it works listen man it's been
four years and i've kept
75 pounds off okay i i put on 50 pounds
i lost like 125 [ __ ] pounds that's
rick
i was and here's what the problem was
when i first walked into justin
fortune's gym
it was justin fortune who said to me
joey the party's over i saw you walking
into your car you know justin does have
no shortage of words yeah there's no
like niceness from justin justin at the
time was pacquiao's boxing coach and i
would buy weed next door and he would
see me walk into the car and out of the
car and i'd walk over say hello but as
soon as he tell me walk in the gym i
always had to do something yeah joy when
are you gonna come to the gym walk
around hit the bag no no finally i met a
guy from boston his name was macafole
who i spoke to yesterday he's in new
york training james franco right now oh
wow mac is a bad [ __ ] mac is one
of my closest friends in l.a i talked to
maca three times a week on the phone
about the bag yesterday we talked about
shadow boxing he spoke to me about
shadow boxing the importance of shadow
boxing he's 68 these shadow boxes are
now worth that jesus okay so you
understand me it's all you know when you
talk to those guys you're like one
sounds stupid for not having yeah you're
a [ __ ] idiot you know he does sit-ups
he does push-ups
so he trains people during the week at
mcafoe you go down and you give him 20
bucks he'll train you for six rounds and
the thing you hit the [ __ ] bag with
him he teaches you how to punch he
teaches you how to [ __ ] barry i mean
it's a it's a great thing because
working out you learn
i always my dick gets hard when i learn
i i don't care what i'm learning about
if you take the time out of your day to
teach me something
that means the world to me you know
so he would talk to me every day and go
joey you're putting on the pounds i
remember at this time i would weigh
myself on the scale and i couldn't even
weigh myself what else the scale stops
at 350. oh jesus i would have to go to
like a cattle house to [ __ ] wait i'm
not kidding you but i know at 350 the
scale will go ding
thing which meant there's no hope
there was no hope and i finally went to
a heart doctor who had the scale
and i remember him looking at me going
he goes you know you're 418.
and i remember i couldn't even make eye
contact yeah i couldn't even make eye
contact
it must have been did you ever think
about just like
all right it's over i'll just eat until
i die no i i know i didn't want to die i
knew at that point that this had to end
so yeah i had gotten off the coke i
outlived the culture okay did i put you
off the coast i just outlived the coke
so this gotta i got when that doctor
told me i had a strong heart he goes
your heart is very strong so what i did
was i went to justin's
and i would hit the bag nakafala goes i
don't want you to do nothing i want you
to not i want you to stretch a little
bit
and i want you to stand in front of the
bag and i want you to punch the bag like
this
and i'm going to stop you every once in
a while and i mean i mean i would have
to stop after 15 seconds
15 seconds of punching i would have to
stop
and i'll have to wear two pair of
underwear
two two lead because i would pee my
pants i still pee my pants
yeah a little bit or i got a [ __ ]
piss real quick if i catch my breath i
mean i'm not lying to you people i have
no reason to line a little body and i
would punch the bag and i did that for
like six weeks
and i lost weight but i didn't lose the
sufficient amount of weight that i
thought i would lose it's [ __ ] hard
you want to lose like 50 60 pounds i
want to lose 50 pounds in a day yeah you
know what i'm saying and i would lose
three pounds
and that three pounds or one pound but
i didn't understand that dieting was
everything and that christmas
like i was working out with maca maybe
a month and i did go on a diet i ate one
cheeseburger instead of four
i did i ate one egg two eggs instead of
five you know [ __ ] like that
and then i read something i read that uh
they did a study that americans could
work out all day long but if they didn't
diet they wouldn't lose any weight
and i knew they were talking about me
yeah i knew they would you know we live
in an age now where you go on the
internet i had a friend that's very
heavy and she called me up on there she
goes i overheard and one of your things
that you're doing kettlebells because i
bought a 10 pound and i do them in my
house
and i go how'd you learn she goes i go
online and i found this one webpage that
really broke it down for me
it's a beginner webpage so you put the
weight between your legs you know you
stretch the stretches before
people are very embarrassed it takes a
certain person to go to a why
and work out but what you're gonna find
is years ago christy miller was a comic
out of new york she saw new york sweet
girl i used to hang out in the store
this was way before i ever thought it
dreamed and it's a funny story but it's
not
it just goes to show you that there's
human compassion in the gym
there really is so what you think is
going to happen to you in the gym those
days are over with yeah when you walk
into a gym after a week people look at
you different and they gain respect for
you
they'll come up to you and go hey man
thanks for coming in and you're like
well i'm doing three minutes on the
stairmaster i'm dying
because they're telling you they've been
there
so the first thing uh
she dice used to get on me dice and
steve simone really did you know that
well dice always got on me
always always and he got on me as a
friend
joey what the [ __ ] you're getting bigger
than the stage
joey what the [ __ ] you got to work won't
you come work out with me in the cage
you know
and it just you know people help you
people love you so they say little
things to you sometimes you get mad
because you're like who the [ __ ] are you
but they love you
or they've been there they've been there
once somebody's been there you gotta
listen to that person i think i'm just
saying go listen no more war between me
and you
what do i gotta do and they'll tell you
joey do that you get people that go oh
you gotta clean a mountain and no
no those are the people that fail as
personal trainers because they're
putting so you gotta read the person's
psychology you're not gonna have them
running [ __ ] sprints if he hasn't
worked out in three years their bones
hurt when you weigh 10 pounds overweight
your bones hurt yeah you go for a long
walk your feet hurt yeah you know so you
got to start slow
you know put that you got to look at
everybody is different every [ __ ]
body is different what works for lee
isn't going to work for joey it works
but joey isn't gonna work for timmy what
works for anybody it's just really
[ __ ] scary
and when i read that article i broke i
remember marilyn martinez
for some reason she pushed weight
watchers and i had a friend in denver
who was huge who was huge
when when i first did comedy this guy
wouldn't come to my comedy shows because
he was embarrassed and he told me one
time
but his wife talked him into going to
weight watchers and he became a marathon
runner wow and today this guy is a
[ __ ] rail he eats protein because
weight watchers you know when i went to
the county jail i used to go to jail all
the time
and i noticed when i got out of jail
even though i ate chocolate at night and
potato chips i lost weight
when you get out of jail like county
jail people like dog you tightened up a
little bit yeah because portions are
small portions are small and your body
adjusts them you know when we go to roma
you could go to roma and get two
sandwiches macaroni and cheese roasted
peppers and two sodas well i give you
one sandwich with no sides and you'll
get just as full yeah
if you really think about it and that's
what they do they slow you down you know
till this day for breakfast i eat one
egg with one piece of wheat toast
i can use america wants two eggs
go one egg
you'll be full if you scramble that egg
and cut there's a piece of ham
there's a piece of ham you buy at the
supermarket okay you cut that in half
it's a point
let's say weight once it gives you 44
points a day it's a point for half a
piece of ham so you fry that ham
you make one egg one egg is two points
that's three points an english muffin
it's two points
so for five points you ate breakfast
it's not the breakfast you're used to
eating right that's why you gotta eat it
with fruit
you gotta devour [ __ ] a pineapple or
a cantaloupe or a watermelon or two
apples and then drink a gallon of
[ __ ] water for me it was coca-cola
that was killing me so i went to diet
coke not the healthiest choice
but for then it worked
that's what people understand for now it
works well you do you don't know what
you're doing to you it works for now you
have no idea what i was [ __ ] drinking
okay so i'm drinking three diet cokes
and water instead of 16 solid cokes a
day shut your [ __ ] mouth okay so i'll
glow in the dark for a few months who
gives a [ __ ] mind your [ __ ] business
because it's all sacrifices it's all
little sacrifice it's the same thing
with life man with this and you do it
every day
that's the thing when i wake up in the
morning what do i put now my stay
[ __ ] i don't i know you're
bored with that stupidity and i know
you're bored with the church i know
you're bored but hey wash your dick i do
it to show you people that you have to
do something every [ __ ] day
you know i don't tweet on the weekends
but monday through friday i'm on there
my day every [ __ ] day is the same
thing once i went to weight watchers i
went with rick
and that really changed things i i
realized that when you go to roma
you get a when you go to subway you get
a foot long with the bag
and you get the soda you go to foot long
you get six inch
with a cup of soup and a green tea you
accomplish the same thing
that's what you learn instead of eating
two steaks with a baked potato you eat a
half a steak with a salad that's all
they want you to do number two
eating out is done yeah that's the thing
eating out is done going on a diet is
not a diet it's a lifestyle
it's a lifestyle for the better i'm
still a fat [ __ ] but my lifestyle is a
hundred percent better i go to physicals
i get a finger put up my ass i [ __ ]
gotta now they gotta put a tube you
don't gotta send [ __ ] in the mail to a
doctor
why did you know that when you hit 50
and i thought that was a joke i thought
it was a [ __ ] joke
about six seven months ago i got a call
from kaiser and my wife had kaiser
insurance because i was on kaiser's
insurance yeah and i was on screen
actors guild insurance
i get a call from [ __ ] kaiser and
they're like hey man
uh this is dr such and such we reassem
in our records you turned 50. we're
gonna put a cup in the mail we'd like
for you to put feces in there mail it
back i thought it was like league
playing
i'm like all right whatever send it to
me i'm [ __ ] weak late i got a cup in
the mail
i looked at this cup and they're like
you know [ __ ] in the cup it gave me the
instructions
i'm like i'm not [ __ ] no cup they
called me again we never received a cup
of your feces in it what the [ __ ] why
are you so why do you want my [ __ ] for
i'm gonna mail you a [ __ ] cup full of
[ __ ]
so then when my wife quit her job they
stopped calling so i have to [ __ ] in the
cup well the other dad went for a
physical
and they said to me joey by the way when
you're 51 you have to do this
colonoscopy yeah where they stick a
camera up your [ __ ] or something
your [ __ ] your [ __ ] and you gotta
they put you out [ __ ] you
you're gonna put me out and put
something in my ass that's called rape
where i'm [ __ ] from you know what i'm
saying you want to put something up my
ass i want to watch it yeah you know
[ __ ] you you're gonna put some on my ass
when i'm passed i gotta take my wife i'm
thinking i gotta get take my wife to a
ceremony we're gonna put a camera up my
[ __ ] ass while i'm passed out i [ __ ]
it but you got to do what they test you
now for hepatitis b if you're over fifth
uh
between certain ages
and the doctor told me goes on something
else you got a [ __ ] in a cup and i was
like blown away this last week because
this doctor is my main man dr wax like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
guys yeah you got a [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
cup you have to [ __ ] in a cup you got to
read the thing what you could eat when
you can't eat then you got a [ __ ] and
you scrape a little bit off and then
mail it to us and we'll take care of it
i got the envelope staring at me i put
on my bulletin board i've been thinking
about [ __ ] in the [ __ ] cup all week
but that's health what are you gonna
[ __ ] do you know i got insurance they
offer it to me i gotta do it the worst
thing for me to come and think i call
them [ __ ] cancer i i need to come
over and film that whole process okay i
just i
can't just seeing it and then
the club
we're gonna do it no this isn't a cup i
gotta scrape it and put it with a spoon
on like an envelope and i'm gonna put
under a microscope and look at my [ __ ]
in this [ __ ] day and age somebody
wants to look at your [ __ ] that's like
the [ __ ] that's like the crystal ball
of the future to see what's up your
[ __ ] but
you know it's uh
the first step in anything is is rough
you know this morning in the shower i
was thinking about when i first moved
here and the guys i hung out with
and every saturday they celebrated
something
twice a month
what are you doing saturday we're
getting together we're going to have a
party it's something such as birthday
and they asked me what i was doing and
whether i was doing something or not i
refused to go to their stupid [ __ ]
parties
because they were comedians and on
saturday nights you're working
if you're not working you're out there
first trying to do a spot and then after
you do a spot then you could drink a
snort coke and [ __ ] somebody up the ass
i'm with you
but your main job as a comic is to do
that [ __ ] spot
you know your main job is whatever is to
do that spot that i don't listen bro i
don't give a [ __ ] about your schedule i
i don't give a [ __ ] about you know the
greatest line of movie history besides
the movie line with rocky is alec
baldwin
in in that movie uh grilling gary ross
when he does the speech he goes good
father [ __ ] you a good father you supply
for your family you want a boat
with your friends playing you know you
follow them saying to you all that
people make a big deal about their lives
[ __ ] you today i got to do i got to go
to knee surgery i gotta have knee
surgery i tore my acl i tore the [ __ ]
thing there's arthritis in there there's
a muscle that [ __ ] up on the side i
thought it was uh the knee you know what
today once i finish this i'm going to
the y i got to ride that bike
i got to keep my heart going i got to do
you political for 50 [ __ ] minutes my
wrist hurts i won't do kettlebells today
there's no jiu-jitsu today i have uh the
live podcast tonight and there's no
jiu-jitsu class there's an open mat up
at street sports i rather [ __ ] do my
wrist still hurts i don't want to land
on the wrist or something so i'm gonna
do the epileptic well there's always
something you could do i'm 51 you think
i want to walk to the [ __ ] wine lose
my parking spot is that what you think
no but i'm doing it anyway
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
you know when i'm home in the mornings
and the baby wakes up
my morning's done
whatever i was working on is done so
guess what i got to get up at 5 30. that
gives me two hours without the baby
because she'll come in any time after 6
30 we wake up anytime after 6 30 to 7 30
she'll come in bouncing running in the
[ __ ] room
and she doesn't understand the concept
of hold on daddy's got to finish this no
yeah you know people don't understand
that yeah you got a schedule that's fine
i don't give a [ __ ] about your schedule
this is what you need to do you know you
need to go for a walk if if if your
mother comes to visit you
that's fine
at one point a day you give her a kiss
and you go i gotta go for a run where
were you going we're gonna have cupcake
no we're not i have cupcakes with paul
i'm gonna go for a [ __ ] run
and people be mad at you but they
respect you
they'll go what the [ __ ] this guy no
cause life goes on you i don't give a
[ __ ] about your party i don't give a
[ __ ] about your thing i have to do this
this is what people in this country
people in general and then they get mad
because they don't get the results they
get out of life well i had to do it no
you have to do nothing well my friend
had a dinner [ __ ] your friend in this
[ __ ] dinner you get there an hour
late and you [ __ ] run or you exercise
or you go swimming or you finish the
chapter in that book i don't give a
how long you know me do i give a [ __ ]
about anything no
when we got a job to do yeah we got a
job to do christmas new year's birthdays
that's all [ __ ] that's for [ __ ]
people who don't want to [ __ ] succeed
we works 24 7. we that's how you got to
do it you look at the people who are
successful
i took the day off because i just what
deserve what [ __ ] deserve what
deserve what do you got coming you got
dick coming yeah dick i get it you're
playing with your kids i'm thinking all
[ __ ] day
i'm thinking of the next move all day i
love myself yeah hit it
what's happening little brother
what you doing you bad [ __ ] over
here schooling these [ __ ] letting
them know they got to get up every day
and watch their [ __ ] nothing changes
you know what i'm saying
nothing changes nothing changes
you know when you were going for the
[ __ ] thing a couple months ago when
you were training for the [ __ ] thing
with john jock
in the afternoon you get home you pick
up draco you hug him you kiss him once
you pick up your child what do you have
on your mind you don't want to go
nowhere right
no man but you still got to get up and
go do your [ __ ] squats right or wrong
right who gives a [ __ ] you got to hug
the kid kiss him and you got to go do
what you got to do could you imagine if
you sat there all day playing with your
son all day it's great and you're a
great father but what would happen to
your house who would support your wife
who would support your kids who would
attain their goals
nothing man nothing gets done nothing
gets done i like these i'm gonna be a
stay-at-home father you're a
stay-at-home [ __ ] is what you [ __ ]
are get out there stab a [ __ ]
how's your son gonna learn from you
[ __ ] i'm gonna stay home and play
tic tac get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
sorry yeah i'm emotional this morning
what's happening my brother
hey you know what i'm wearing the same
boat man you know uh
you know i i like i like going out and
getting the bacon and my wife stays home
and raises draco and teaches them all
day i like that man but i also like
staying home uh you know and
when i'm
not traveling
on the weekends
to an affiliate of mine to teach a
seminar staying home is like vacation i
enjoy staying home when i can because
i'm always out there hustling trying to
make a dollar you know to keep that keep
that rent paid so we're in the same boat
man we got to go out there and slay some
dragons for our family i know i know
every [ __ ] i know you love jiu jitsu
i know you love it i've been around you
for 10 years you love jiu jitsu
but i know i talk to you every night at
10 after 8 when you're driving to teach
and i got to tell you something there's
some nights i know you don't want to be
there you'd rather do something else but
you love jiu jitsu and this is what you
do and you don't give a [ __ ] if the
world ends or the 101 blows up you still
got to be there at 8 30. you know
i don't give a [ __ ] you take a
helicopter it's really amazing how
people call you and they go oh this
isn't working out for me you know you're
lucky joe rogan put you on the podcast
joe rogan put me on the podcast but it's
the work i do after joe rogan
you know these [ __ ] nobody
everybody wants to [ __ ] go to heaven
but nobody wants to die eddie so
it's just uh it's just the thing that i
know you know you're an older gentleman
at eight o'clock at night you're already
thinking about putting your feet up and
getting your balls licked you gotta go
[ __ ] teach and smell feet and [ __ ]
like that you don't need the aggravation
but you do it
because that's what needs to be [ __ ]
done
i have no choice there's no choice and
you know i ain't complaining
it's a great job man you know teaching
people how to strangle each other
uh i'm blessed
it's surreal i can't believe that's my
job but you know you're right sometimes
you just want to [ __ ] stay home and
be tired
from uh
you know doing different things during
the day sometimes you want to stay home
but
no matter how i feel when i'm driving
the class or anything i know once i
start teaching i know once no matter
what i'm feeling i can have a hangover
or whatever once i start teaching class
um i'm i'm obsessed and the passion just
flows you know
it's it's a rare rare rare time where
i'm actually teaching and i don't love
it
no i know i know it might come you know
it's really weird man i've been going to
jiu jitsu now for a year you know what i
did last friday night at seven o'clock
eddie when all my friends are doing this
and this i went to the beginner class
and you know what i saw friday night
eddie and i know for you it ain't much
but for me it's my i did the whole floor
of hip escapes do you know when i
[ __ ] started at that school i could
only do three hip escapes and i'd be out
of breath and i peed my pants and i'd
have to [ __ ] take my g-top off and
breathe
do you know that i go the whole length
of the [ __ ] floor now with hip
escapes bro perfect hip escapes too the
ass all the way up to me that means more
than somebody giving me 10 million
dollars eddie
that's a beautiful thing man it's
beautiful man for me that means more to
me this friday i got a busted acl my
knee is gone they're doing surgery the
last week of july
but you know today i can't do nothing
because i got a podcast and i got an
audition i don't have a jiu jitsu class
in the afternoon but [ __ ] tomorrow
i'm gonna go to jiu jitsu and even if i
can't do a half guard or whatever i
don't give a [ __ ] because i know it
affects the rest of my life
eddie i know when i get on stage in the
back of my mind i know that i did the
whole length of the floor on hip escapes
that might not be much to you
but to a guy like me that gives me a ton
of [ __ ] confidence when i go on stage
you
know absolutely man that's what you get
to does you're reminded every day of the
uh of things that you were [ __ ] at
and all of a sudden you master you
realize that you could master anything
and uh you know what you learn in
jiu-jitsu just reminds you of how
magical your body is and you know if
you're not doing jiu jitsu you're just
driving to work and you're sitting in
your office all day and by the time you
get home at night uh you're tired and
you eat you watch some tv and then you
crash you're not reminded how magical
your body is so you think you can't do
[ __ ] you think like you have no
confidence in yourself but what jiu
jitsu does is it reminds you every time
you go in you sucked at a certain
technique and now and then you get
really good at it and then you get
unconscious with it and then you get
magical with it like where
you're rolling and your body does does
the move and you didn't even you just
kind of like just oversaw
the whole movement and your body just
did a lot of stuff you didn't know what
it did then you realized wow man
i could apply this to anything i could i
could master anything you can do
anything so that's what jiu jitsu does
that's that's how you know what people
always say oh you get to change my life
events you do you get the things i like
that and people always talk about it but
they don't really get down to
the specifics man the specifics are your
body is magical you teach it how to do
something you do it over and over and
over again it'll do it by itself and
it'll do it by itself way better than
you
commanding and you doing it it's pretty
incredible and
that's that's how you get the chances of
that because you realize that man if i
get into any trade or any you realize
you can be a lawyer
you really can be a doctor you know you
really can do anything all you got to do
is study do the drills do the homework
and you can do anything
it's amazing i don't get carried away
i'm only good at hip escapes
everything else everything else my
body's not magical i'm only good at hip
escapes and i can do two of them in a
row then i gotta tap out for a second
until i get you back in my guard what's
up my brother
and i just uh just woke my ass up
no i'm never up at this time the only
time i'm up at this time is to take a
piss i'm like walking like a zombie to
class and uh
and that's how [ __ ] up i'm walking
down the hall like a zombie take a leak
and then i walk back i'm never up
rarely talking just get on your podcast
it's the only time i'm up hey ten years
ago you were just finishing eating [ __ ]
the indian was just making the indian
was just wearing off ten years ago you
know what i'm saying
at six in the morning you were just
coming too the feather you found the
feather on your chest you didn't know
what happened you're like what the [ __ ]
happened there was a feather on my chest
that went out i'm missing a shoe
you were leaving balloons in germany
you got a shoe in your backpack
so what's going on
so what's going on this weekend
this sunday in hollywood at the
florentine gardens uh my first
jiu jitsu event i've been
working on this and brainstorming on
this for a very long time and me and
victor davila the he he's the spanish
commentator for the ufc he's uh
we're partners in this and and the name
of the show is eddie bravo invitational
um also known as ebi we're doing it this
sunday
uh doors open at 4 30 at the florentine
gardens you can get your tickets at
eddie bravo invitational.com
uh it's
edi's 2 16 man submission only
tournaments we're doing the 145 and 170
and it's uh you know
there's really nothing out there man
like it's kind of like abu dhabi with a
bunch of weight classes 16 men in each
weight class invitation only and
qualifying only and but we're doing it
submission only and we do have overtime
rounds that there is no submission uh
the the overtime rounds are submission
based you know so and they have nothing
to do with wrestling or takedowns or
anything most you just determined to
take it into overtime it really comes
down to who the best wrestler is and
when that happens you know i'm not
against wrestling but what that what
that happens is you have a guy who
doesn't know any jiu jitsu he just
wrestles his whole life he'll stall
in regulation just to get to overtime
and then over time it's first points win
you know and
basically comes down to wrestling so we
we fixed that that was a flaw in the jiu
jitsu game you know again
wrestling is a beautiful art and
everyone should know wrestling but
a jiu jitsu matches shouldn't be decided
on wrestling that's that's what we're
doing here at ebi you know they're
submission based so
um
there's a youtube video that i made uh
going over and explaining the overtime
rules if you just go to uh youtube and
search eddie bravo invitation
invocational
overtime rules i explain it takes 13
minutes to expose that i can't do it
here i need visuals to explain a thing
um i'm very really really excited about
it in the 145 the number one seed is
just glover and in the 170 the number
one seed is gary telling him two
monsters in the jiu jitsu world and we
got that ten planet guys you know geo
martinez and his brother richie martinez
they're both in the two you know it's
the the whole
my whole format is designed to to
promote as much urgency within the
fighters to make it exciting for uh tv
you know we're basically shooting a
pilot for spanish tv there's a spanish
uh a major network
really really interested in this they're
going to be there they're sponsoring the
event
uh the the ring announcer is that works
for the the network so it's not sold yet
it's still a pilot but we're trying
we're trying to get this on tv and the
spanish market is embracing jiu jitsu
way more than the american market the
american market they don't care they
just want titties on tv and you know in
mexico jiu-jitsu
is on a meteoric lives it's just like
the ufc they love it mexico is just
embracing jiu jitsu they're they're um
so that's what we're going we're going
to the markets that are embracing a
market where we don't have to try to
pitch go to a pitch meet in america you
know pitch meetings are you trying to
explain how awesome jiu jitsu and how
cool it would be to be on tv and they're
like where the titties at where's the
the you know what was the new
uh
jersey shore that's what they're looking
for so we're not even going to try to
put it on american tv they're going to
have to
see it
be successful
in latin market and then hopefully
they'll pick it up but
that's this sunday florentine gardens uh
tickets only 25 bucks again you can get
on the website and buy the tickets there
i hope to see all you guys i hope to see
a bunch of deaf squatters there it's
gonna my goal is to have them to create
the most exciting jiu jitsu tournament
possible that's my goal i might fail
miserably but that is my goal and the
rules and everything were
the whole focus was to be exciting
enough not just for
the hardcore jiu-jitsu fans but for
everybody worldwide just a casual ufc
fan that's what we're aiming at
that's a beautiful [ __ ] thing
that's a beautiful thank you very much i
knew i knew what you now when submission
only there's no points that's what
you're telling me
yeah no points no point
so that's what kills the game there's
been a point format in jiu jitsu since
1996 since the first tournament in the
united states and there's been no tv or
just because the point system is just it
just um
encourages stalling you know as soon as
a guy is up on two points maybe he took
a guy down or past the guard he'll hold
you know he'll hold and shuttle he'll
stall there are guys that don't give you
know that that are exciting in the point
format there are guys like the key and
cornelius
mendez marcelo garcia but generally
overall uh you know you got four matches
in your division
your first couple matches you don't want
to blow your wad you don't want so you
get a couple points and you hold that's
great for you and your teammates but it
sucks for the people sitting in the
stands people watching at home so we're
trying to cater to the people watching
at home which is something uh jiu jitsu
promoters have never done before because
in jiu jitsu they cater to the
competitors because the competitors
pay the bills they're the the promoters
are making money off the competitors
they're paying 120 dollars each so
they're making it
uh
um
all about the competitors when we're
we're trying to make it all about the
audience the spectator we're focusing on
them which uh no one has really done
before everyone's focusing on
making the competitor happy so we're
trying to make the audience happy and
and hopefully this works out and we've
done our best me and victor david busted
her ass and it's going to be a great
show man i hope to see everybody at the
florentine gardens this sunday doors
open at 4 30. if you're going to the
mundials the world championships
uh you know if you get bored there you
know you go you know you go tell your
buddy let's get out of here let's go to
ebi dude this is killing me you can do
that [ __ ] you know it's only uh the moon
diaz is probably like 30 minutes away
from florentine garden soon
we're hoping to pack it up make a lot of
noise and
and just to make sure everyone has a
good time and and people talk about it
in a great way and and we just keep
going and we keep doing ebi grand prix
ebi we're going to do ebi women and
children you know just a tournament with
just women and and children and teens uh
brackets you know um there's so many
amazing kids out there doing jiu jitsu
they're virtuosos
that's
the kids are sometimes more entertaining
than the adults you know a lot of times
actually and so are the women you know
watching girls and and women do jiu
jitsu and seeing how good they are
that's pretty fascinating as well so
we're gonna look ebi's gonna encompass
um
everybody and everybody does forget you
you know
women children old ladies you know
five-year-olds uh people with cerebral
palsy uh jiu-jitsu um
everybody does judith so you have no
excuse there are people with cerebral
palsy that do jiu jitsu so if you're out
there thinking oh my god i can't do it
i'm gonna get hurt there are people with
cerebral palsy doing jiu jitsu there's a
guy named kyle maynard who has no arms
and no legs he does jiu jitsu there's
guys with missing legs
those guys are missing arms baby
jiu-jitsu you have no excuse
not to eat you did you
you know it's funny there's a there's a
guy up with john jocks it's a 72 year
old black belt
they just sent me a picture of him one
of the guys javier and
uh i guess he had a heart attack in his
50s or something like that that really
inspires the [ __ ] out of here hegan
machado's got a kid that had a heart
attack an hour after going to jiu jitsu
eddie bravo he had open heart surgeon he
went back to class he's a purple belt
now
i was rolling with him i couldn't
believe i'm like you're not scared he
goes no they fixed my heart i'm back
it really is amazing
how better i've got as a comedian since
i started jiu jitsu already
i've improved
and how has it helped you in comedy
confidence whenever i listen eddie for
me to walk into jiu jitsu i'm scared
because i don't know anything i do not
know
and it's a scary thing for me and
when i would walk out of jiu jitsu and
there'd be a little bit of sweat on my
shirt or a lot of sweat on my shirt
whether i reviewed techniques whether i
reviewed
a hip escape whether i reviewed
you know escaping from the mount or or a
sweep from the mount
when i walked out of eddie i felt like i
did something that was out of my comfort
zone
and when you do something that's out of
your comfort zone i can go kick box all
day long i could do muay thai all day
long i'd go there and do the four rounds
and learn the technique for the week and
spa and it's another day for me because
i've been doing it since i was five with
rashad's father he was my first karate
teacher
but wrestling and jujitsu anything on my
back i never had confidence of
so whenever i walk out of jiu jitsu
that's my accomplishment for the week i
know i did something
my goal is to do two sessions a week at
this age that's all i can handle
especially if i do kettlebells and if i
do the epileptical you know i'm
non-testosterone i'm overweight but i
gotta tell you something many for me to
go in there and just i do little things
and they're such a big accomplishment
for me
if i pass a guard one week to me that's
like winning the [ __ ] silver at the
moon dials
to me to me to joe diaz to me when i uh
hold somebody in my closed guard and i
get them on my in a half guard and i
hold them there for five minutes even if
whatever even if i just break his
posture to me i made an accomplishment i
did better than the week before
do you know what exactly
yeah most people they have a
misconception of how uh
tough jiu-jitsu is and how they think
they're just gonna be a bunch of sweaty
bald uh mma fighters you're gonna go in
a cage and they're gonna throw you
against the cage and they're going to
smash you man
at 10 planet hq downtown l.a we got two
beginner classes a day two we have
there's one in the daytime there's one
at night and sometimes there's two at
night uh the day classes are just filled
with beginners that know nothing my
instructors javon graham and scott ross
they walk everybody they hold their
hands walk them through the beginner
classes are
are tailor tailor-made for people that
know nothing
nothing so by the time you get to my
class my class is the advanced class
you know by the time you get there
you'll you'll have some weapons in your
pocket and you'll have confidence and
you'll know and and everyone that walks
in and and finally takes their first
class they all say the same thing
they're like man i had no idea i was
gonna love it so much and how fun and
and uh easy
easier they thought you know it was
easier than they thought it was gonna be
you know it's like most jiu jitsu
schools
have a big a good begin a beginner class
and if they don't then that you know
it's kind of tough it really is they're
going to throw in the beginners and with
the advanced guys that's you got to you
got to have some big balls to do that
as a beginner but you know find the
local jiu-jitsu school and ask them how
you know
how many beginner classes they have a
week and
that you know if they have
you know at least two to four then
you'll be fine just hit those for six
months a year and then
you slowly make your way to the advanced
class but uh like i said at hq now we
got two beginning classes a day and
they're still man there's like 20 25
guys per beginning class every day
packed with guys who don't know anything
and by the time i get them by the time
they transition to advanced class they
have some serious confidence and flow
right with the advanced guys it doesn't
take that long maybe a year you know
time flies if you've got to be in the
beginner class for a year
that's going to go by so quick and and
plus if you're scared you want you just
want to stay there anyways you don't you
don't want to you know
transition to the advanced class until
you're fully ready and fully have your
confidence on track
what nobody remembers eddie is that i
knew scott ross when he was a nerdy
writer at the comedy store
and he was a sweetheart of a kid he
didn't say two [ __ ] words
he used to sit there with nerdy glasses
in the corner and ask me questions about
comedy i always loved him and one day i
walked into hq when you were on la brea
and i think he was a blue belt and he
was a completely different man his body
had changed his back of chains he had
long hair
he was smiling
he came right over and grabbed my leg
and now i watch his drills every day
every day he already posted his drills
right now
by [ __ ] seven o'clock scott ross
already posted hq drills on facebook
and i sit there and i look at the
quarter guard transition to the backyard
and my head [ __ ] explodes i mean it's
[ __ ] amazing what scott's doing down
there and i spoke to him i spoke to him
a few weeks ago and i told him once i
figure out i really wanted to take some
time with me and he was [ __ ] open to
it so i mean
scott's a great guy he even told me
there's a train from my house
to hq
yes that is that's correct there's a
train from my house to hq that my wife
could pick me up on the way home at 11
on mondays and wednesdays because those
are the days she either works either or
so i spoke to him already you know and
uh it's pretty [ __ ] interesting the
things i'm learning and how i'm feeling
lately since i started and i took your
advice on one thing when you uh did
metamoris the second this last time
you spoke about how you were talking to
him throughout the match
yeah you spoke how you wanna and it was
bri you made me laugh so much you're
like i don't why am i talking [ __ ] to
somebody i'm gonna talk something funny
because i don't want a mad guy wrestling
with me i've been doing that lately
eddie
and i've been [ __ ] people up because
you know you know once they take me down
i'm like you [ __ ] i can't believe
you did this to me now i'm gonna get you
and we both start [ __ ] laughing and i
get them that's my world now once i got
you laughing it's my [ __ ] world but
uh no no eddie i learned a lot from you
and you're good at what you do and
i watch all your [ __ ] [ __ ] on youtube
and you're my brother and i love you and
i'm going i called i'm taking george
with me and uh john evans
i'm taking beautiful argentina george
and john evans so i will be there
sunday cheering you on eddie man
you know when i met you you were a
[ __ ] dj at some [ __ ] strip club
where i couldn't afford a hand job and
now look at you
remember i would go out there with you
and rogan i'd stand there cause i didn't
have 20 bucks for a hand job i just
stand there and look at your records how
you doing bro
you got the temptations papa was a
rolling stone
and now you're
you're you know you're the elite of the
elite
every day i gotta answer a question
about you every [ __ ] day
i answer an eddie bravo question
every [ __ ] day
wow that's crazy that's crazy every day
i answer an eddie bravo question you
know it used to be joe rogan questions
are they bringing back fear factor
you know is he real did he really kill a
mountain lion
but now it's uh
it's uh it's all you the last especially
since metamoris i always get something
about eddie bravo at some point in the
day
and it makes me laugh so uh i wish you
luck eddie with all everything i will be
there sunday with bells on
i will not be competing so tell them i
will not be competing
but jojo
but joe jiu jitsu will make a [ __ ]
appearance on sunday i will be there
sober no no reefer how the [ __ ] is that
thanks very much man eddie bravo how the
[ __ ] is that i went to prison
i was in a halfway house
when i was in the halfway house i gave
them two hot uas for cocaine
they put me in outpatient rehab i i went
for three weeks
i was married i've been arrested half my
life nobody could stop me from smoking
reefer
i went to jiu jitsu
for seven months and i decided i had to
stop smoking reefer because i couldn't
wrestle with people
what does that tell you about something
i'll leave you with that just to let you
know how much it's changed me in so many
ways so thank you for
showing me jiu jitsu brother i love you
to death
thank you for having me man and i'll
talk to you later my friend have a great
day thank you for calling
there you have it you dirty [ __ ] if
you're not doing nothing on sunday and
you're in the valley or something let's
all meet over at eddie's place about
five let's go support his first event
i'm sure a lot of the brothers
they're gonna beat down they're trying
to get ari and all of us to go down
there with some [ __ ] templar shirts
and jump up and down it's uh
it's always a great thing to see one of
your brothers uh going for one of their
dreams you know
and if you know anything about eddie
this is one of his [ __ ] dreams so
let's go down it put together what
[ __ ]
that's pretty hysterical
you went to the strip club and you
couldn't afford that
i just sit there
looking at the albums looking oh man
that's nice furniture speaking of albums
i don't think i told you when i went
down to steve simone you know his buddy
ryan who owns the the burrito place yeah
yeah yeah he's told me about a couple
yeah he um i think i think he probably
met you at the store once but on one of
uh
steve's podcast we were talking about
how my dad and i would always uh quote
bill cosby himself that album so he
bought me the final he bought me the
vinyl version of it
so now i have like a vinyl version of
the build of that bill cosby album in my
house what are you gonna do i have to
have to buy i have to find a record
player
like i i don't have one i don't even
know where to look for one but
i would just
hearing albums like oh [ __ ]
so thank you you better buy a [ __ ]
record player that's good you're getting
into something [ __ ] i love you
let me give you some shout outs to some
beautiful [ __ ] people all right are
you stunned i want to sure yeah kirby
mckenzie you know i love you he does he
does he's a good guy i'm saying you do
yeah i do love curtains
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'll stab
you with this heat pencil
d gus six ounces i love you rob johnston
i love you too nikki pompa what's the
story
jessica s get it together
bill man for rest i love you too and
aunt l.a you're always a bad
[ __ ] always uh supporting the
[ __ ] cause i don't know if you guys
follow ufc or you give a [ __ ]
robbie lawler versus matt brown was
announced yesterday yeah break this down
because sacramento we've had matt brown
for a while but when you came in you
were like that's basically like godzilla
versus oh my god robbie lala just
beat up [ __ ] jake ellenberger the
other day poor jake ellenberger
i'm a fan of jake's i know he's a fan of
the [ __ ] podcast but once i saw him i
saw him doing the anthony robbins thing
talking to himself in the cage i knew
the confidence was low and robbie lawler
read that also and just started
attacking him with high kicks and
whatnot robbie lawler's a [ __ ]
brawler
robbie lawler's a guy that's been around
the game i recognize yeah and he's
putting it all together now all the
stars are aligned he lost the uh
hendricks in the championship the five
rounder okay you know some people felt
he won i you know i felt hendrick
squeaked it out you know who the [ __ ] am
i i'm not a judge but i also uh know he
comes to brawl matt brown the other end
has been a [ __ ] monster yeah
yeah eric silva eric silva is still in
the [ __ ] you know still shaking his
head going wrong
you know but eric silva don't get me
wrong that was a hell of a fight if
anybody watched it and i know today's a
ufc-based [ __ ] card but what the [ __ ]
we're just talking about getting healthy
and getting in shape
uh so that got announced yesterday for
sacramento july 26th i'm [ __ ] very
excited about that that that's a
that's a great [ __ ] car let me talk
about on it real quick here
uh i'm back on the strong bone because
my knee is hurting so i'm doing some
surgery july at the end of july i'm
gonna go strong until [ __ ] july with
the knee he want to give me a quarter
zone shot yesterday but i said no he's
going to shoot my leg
with some uh
uh
uh cartilage healer
to start working on the cartilage but he
still has to go in there and clean out
the the uh
the uh to whatever the [ __ ] you call it
the arthritis whatever the [ __ ] you call
it so
i've been taking the strong bone again
listen man for all your [ __ ] needs
for supplement needs i'm not kidding you
everybody else is [ __ ] outdated
whether it's the shroom tech sport the
shroom tech immune
the digestive
digest enzymes they got now you know
what ana is getting better every [ __ ]
day with their products i mean just
alpha brain alone i feel [ __ ]
tremendous go to honor.com see what they
got see if there's anything you like
anything that will they have a
money-back guarantee on their parking
products go to joeydears.net go see what
my tour dates are if i'm coming to your
hometown with t-shirts whatever the [ __ ]
you want to buy a ghee patch whatever
the [ __ ] you want to buy while you're
looking at that look at the on it box
press the word in church church
c-h-u-r-c-h press the code in church get
10 percent off go look and see what
honor has for you they got something
it's
the alphabet i'm not telling you
everything works for me i use the hemp
protein the acai i use the hemp protein
the chocolate but i switch up on
proteins from time to time just so they
taste better there's no better tasting
[ __ ] protein than protein than the
hemp forest chocolate no better tasting
chocolate it is [ __ ] delicious aubrey
went out of his way to get the best
cocoa [ __ ] beans there are in the
world i mean uh all jokes aside it's
[ __ ] tremendous protein if you're
looking for that just something to get
you started in the morning you know you
mix it with water you put in your glue
glue machine whatever the [ __ ] it is to
the amino acids in your back like a
[ __ ] soldier go to honor.com trust me
i wouldn't break your balls about this
if it wasn't working for you maybe
you're thinking of starting a program
maybe you're already starting a program
you need a little extra zip just give
one one little thing of shroom tech uh
sport you're not gonna you're gonna feel
[ __ ] great when you're working out
you're gonna go wow yesterday i ran two
miles today i ran three miles go to
honor.com also to one of my favorite
[ __ ] people in the world because i
can't tell you how much i save you if
you go through these people that dollar
shave club you're a man you got a wife
she shaves a [ __ ] you want to shave
your [ __ ] they got everything for you
for that why are you spending 22 bucks
for raises every month why are you going
to some [ __ ] place and waiting online
why why why why you [ __ ] live off
your time i don't know how much time you
got left get a mail to your house amazon
does a [ __ ] great job i don't even
know if they use amazon i'm just telling
you that they mail the [ __ ] raises to
y'all so you got three different
programs they got a dollar six dollars
and nine dollars you get four [ __ ]
sets of blades sent to your house every
[ __ ] month that's it for one low cost
a dollar six dollars and nine dollars if
you want to try the six dollar plant
it's tremendous it's a double blade the
nine dollars a double blade with a halo
strip they also have a post shave
[ __ ] thing they have the the shaving
cream the cocoa butter thing the shave
cream to eliminate [ __ ] ingrown hairs
they also have the one wipe charlies for
your [ __ ] and your nutsack if you're
in a rush and you want to get your balls
licked and you don't want to show up
smelling like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
dog
a freak without warning like what mama
look yeah my mama look at the egg you
don't want to smell like i'm on the look
of the yay so you got to [ __ ] wipe
your nuts all right also nutrition at
its best naturebox.com
nutrition snacks at their best
naturebox.com
i can't say it enough
naturebox.com has blown me away whether
it's the cocoa almonds the spicy
pistachios the sesame sticks every
[ __ ] month they send me something and
every month that's the
southwestern party [ __ ] mix every
month they sent me something and i go
wow this is [ __ ] good the figs my
daughter lives off those [ __ ] apricot
figs go to naturesbox.com right now look
to see what they got to offer they're
offering you a thing 50 percent off your
first order 50 off your first order 50
[ __ ] percent off your first order for
mentioning the church go to the box on
my page and press joey joey get 50 off
your first order 50 [ __ ] percent 50
i'm giving you a half off the first
order i always take care of you
[ __ ] you understand me value is
what i'm trying to save you some [ __ ]
geezers here nobody ever saves you gears
we're talking about money one dollar six
dollar nine dollars for the raises on it
ten percent off [ __ ] naturesbox.com
50 [ __ ] percent off of the
nutritionist approved [ __ ] snacks go
to naturesbox.com right now press enter
and get 50 off your first order and then
after that you can switch them around
every month but you'll get them sent to
your house right there on the first you
don't gotta go nowhere and get snacks
also again congratulations
they just had a baby nailed it like
peter and my man david i love you guys
to them they're not together i'm just
saying
one guy's the uncle one guy's the dad i
want to i love dave nailed their life i
have their vaper pen at the house it's
tougher than [ __ ] death you could put
wax in there or a [ __ ] oil you could
put gasoline you could put whatever the
[ __ ] you want in that [ __ ] pen you
understand me that's how good [ __ ]
that pen is go to nailbitlife.com
joey is in the [ __ ] box and get 10 or
20 off the first order they also have
gloomy models they don't ship to
everywhere but talk to them about it
nailed it live.com i love these guys
they're family friends from west new
york new jersey
what's up [ __ ] you know you get
emotional when you're talking about i
got emotional about all this [ __ ] cuz i
love these people [ __ ] reach out and
they also give you guys a deal and
that's very important to me yeah you
know how you know you guys know how nate
uh how i know nature box is good because
every time someone says something yo
joey always gives to me i haven't seen
nature box in [ __ ] seven months
i got like a bag of things you're always
like heads so good i got something at
the house for you every next time i see
a dog those cookie moments those coco
woman's that they didn't make a talk
one time they sent me two bags of cocoa
arms i'm like i'm gonna save them for me
[ __ ]
that was the longest [ __ ] week of my
life i was telling me
something happened the other night that
was really interesting to me
uh
i was watching the tv show doesn't
matter what show this guy's
but it's a show that you [ __ ]
don't shut the [ __ ] up about
real housewives
this vapor pen is delicious
i think this is og
they might close no organic is closing
why
because the government or
they sent the letter to the landlord the
landlord's [ __ ] shaking this track
they're gonna blow the place up so no
organic might close for a few months
it's killing me
it's a pain in my [ __ ] ass you know
it's one of the best [ __ ] weed stores
out there no organic
they got some [ __ ] weed now that
killed [ __ ] jesus antonio i'm telling
you right now they got a pr over there
that's so [ __ ] strong
i took one hit off a bomb and went to
burke crisis barbecue i couldn't stop
eating hot dogs
i couldn't stop they were following me
they were chasing me the [ __ ] hot
dogs they were talking to me one [ __ ]
banged it
on the pr
and i smoked that [ __ ] with doug manson
in texas nothing happened i think i did
a pipe
a pipe hit here the one night or the
other candy whatever it didn't do
nothing to me the pr right now and no
organic on burbank will [ __ ] set you
back three days
it's like [ __ ] were you gonna wake up
like what's that dude that woke up with
a beard humble dick
what's his name the dude who went to
sleep for 20 years and he woke up with a
beard and dirty
feet no idea [ __ ]
hump or dink or something like that
that's what happened to you
but it's really funny i i was at home
the other night and the show was on they
had two or three episodes of the show
it's a half hour comedy
and i'm sitting there and and uh
listen it doesn't matter what show it is
it's the it's it's the point i'm trying
to make and i'm watching the show and
i'm sitting there 15 minutes
and this show's killing me but then my
wife comes in and i go i want my wife to
watch what i'm watching so we finished
watching the show we're watching them we
watch another episode that they play on
this show
that's like 15 minutes my wife looks at
me she goes why are we watching this
now guys i'm a [ __ ] idiot i'm a
savage you know
i'm not all there but my wife is white
raised with a great family tennessee you
know she don't drink none of that [ __ ]
she's watching the show she turns over
me she goes this show is [ __ ]
terrible
this show was [ __ ] terrible and i'm
like
god
says this show is [ __ ] great i
watched it last year a couple episodes i
i thought it was okay it's entertaining
at its best at a four
but this show once it gets off the air
nobody ever watched this [ __ ] again
and it's amazing that you talk to people
and and this is the thing so i call lee
right away and i go lee i just watched
that show
you know whatever the [ __ ] you told me
it's the cool thing to watch you said
you know guys when does it end
when does it [ __ ] end when is
something
you went to texas and we in the barbecue
and you gotta wait online for three
hours that ain't cool
that's what people waiting online to be
[ __ ] cool so they go tell somebody
what the [ __ ] they did for three hours
since when is waiting online being cool
it's like these idiots that put those
glasses on
and they sit there like i have glasses
on really you think you're [ __ ] cool
because you got fake
glasses on it makes you look what
people's gonna think you're [ __ ]
smarter because you got glasses on we
live in [ __ ] up times you know when i
do a podcast week it is what the [ __ ] it
is at the end of the day it's it's a fat
[ __ ] that went to prison with a [ __ ]
jew talking stupidity okay
if you want to listen to it you listen
to it okay if not don't listen to it if
you don't like what i'm trying to say
don't listen to it but i don't ever want
you to be hang out with me or do this
because it's a cool thing to do that's a
shitty [ __ ] way that's what society
is about i don't know when i was a kid
next to the benders there was a house
that had richie seidel remember we
talked about this before
little richie that there's a chance that
day that talked about seeing me get
stared at that time and that was crazy
he was a little boy
and he had a sister and every sat friday
and saturday his parents would play
cards his father owned chickadee
chicken place it's like a chicken
delight for white people
chickadee and uh
and
every friday and saturdays but his mom
and dad would play cards and they would
have a different high school babysitter
in there and the whole neighborhood knew
about it so your goal was to go and [ __ ]
the babysitter i was always friends with
the babysitter so i would go over there
and watch richie's kids with whatever
chick you know nine out of ten i didn't
try to [ __ ] nobody they were just
friends but the point being i would go
over there for the latter night of
saturday night
and i remember being a kid in the
seventh and eighth grade and everybody
talking about saturday night live
i was gonna die laughter and i would
watch that live and i'll tell you what
nothing would happen to me samurai night
fever
and i'd sit there and go this is okay at
its best i'm a honeymooners type of
[ __ ] i'm an odd couple type of
[ __ ] i'm a sampling son redfox
was funny on sampling son this is
atrocious or at least it wasn't as funny
to me as everybody said it was
oh my god you gotta watch it and i knew
people who missed their saturday nights
to go home and once in a while and i
would go
oh my [ __ ] god oh my [ __ ] god that
a young man would stay home on a
saturday to watch that [ __ ] i could see
if you were sick or somebody died in
your house and that was the only thing
that was on tv but for you to run home
to watson i like i couldn't [ __ ]
think about i never watched it again and
i learned something that but it wasn't
that i remember i was telling lee the
story when i was a kid i used to go to
every concert the garden the palladium
the ritz if there was a [ __ ] concert
in new york i was there as a high
schooler and we went over and we stubbed
tickets or we [ __ ] robbed somebody
and we we we sold the jewelry to get
tickets to go to these shows but there
was this rich kid his name was ado sawa
he was this little german kid
otto was a [ __ ] nerd in today's
standards nice kid i liked him i had
nothing against otto he got high but i
don't overcompensate he tried really
hard to be [ __ ] cool even though he
was a [ __ ] nerd whatever you guys
call a nerd now today a [ __ ] hipster
or a dork whatever the [ __ ] guy's
name otto was all right he wouldn't hurt
himself he had no male intentions but if
there was a concert we were there and
otto was there with his boys
and i would go to school the next day
and i would be you know we all were
potheads so i would listen to otto tell
stories about the concert night before
how the concert was great and some
concerts we went to were [ __ ] great i
saw some great concerts growing up you
know
the music was great the sound was great
i saw new barbarians with keith richards
you know i'd say i saw some unique
concerts growing up
and there was concerts that just blew
you know black sabbath van halen's blue
black sabbath just blew you know uh the
cars at central park i went to see and
they just blew there's some shows that
you know i [ __ ] suck if you go see me
10 nights in a row i'm not going to be
great 10 nights in a row three of those
nights i'm gonna suck it's just the way
life is maybe the audience is too tight
maybe i got into a fight with my wife
maybe somebody's sick in my family maybe
the [ __ ] flying jew ain't getting
high wake up [ __ ] something's
going on you cannot be 100 every night
and you go out there and every time we
went to a concert i'd always hear otto
talk about how good the concert was
but one day we went to see somebody in
jersey and the concert blew
the concert blew so much even the kids i
went we were like that sucked
and the next day i saw otto with his
contract t-shirt on because god forbid
people didn't know he'd go to a concert
the night before you know if he went to
a show everybody had to know the next
day he had to put the concert t-shirt on
and i remember him being 10 feet away he
didn't know i was there and he was
telling the story about the concert last
night he was awesome and all these
gawkers were they're like really you
weren't you're so lucky and i finally
finally had to go i don't know for
nothing me and these eight gorillas were
at that concert last night and it
[ __ ] sucked the singer oh no and then
after 10 minutes he goes yeah you're
right so then why'd you tell these guys
it was good to be [ __ ] cool that
everything not everything is good and in
this country we've learned that every
day oh my god it was just no
be honest
be [ __ ] honest you're gonna hang with
somebody and do something because
they're [ __ ] cool give me a [ __ ]
break
give me a [ __ ] break
you're gonna speak for yourself you
gotta have your own [ __ ] voice man if
something sucks like the church joey the
church sucks you know what i won't be
mad at you i'd rather you say that than
[ __ ] tell me some [ __ ]
right or wrong why are you lying to
yourself america why the [ __ ] are you
lying to these people that this show
sucks why are you sitting there saying
it's brilliant because your 10 dumb
friends are saying it's brilliant these
[ __ ] dummies that have no voice
that'll never speak out something for
themselves it's always that everybody
[ __ ] else likes that's why i can't
stand going to hollywood i was in
hollywood yesterday i made the left turn
on fairfax yeah i see 15 people waiting
in front of the [ __ ] griddle
let me tell you something there's
nothing i want to do more than make a
youtube run over those 15 people because
they're dead anyway
they're dead anyway 15 people waiting
for eggs to be cool because lindsay
lohan ate there one time before court
but down the block there's an egg joint
and it was empty i pulled in and got a
turkey [ __ ] bagel a bagel on poppy
seed with turkey you understand me so
what [ __ ] price do you pay to be cool
jesus christ to wait online that's
[ __ ] cool so you could tell your
[ __ ] friends those [ __ ] dead beats
that you did that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
anyway
we're at the ice house tonight eight
o'clock
tomorrow night i'm in san diego's and
harrah's and next week we're at the
[ __ ] wise guys in utah myself
and my main man duncan boogaloo trussel
what are you gonna [ __ ] do with your
life that's it that's the church today
in a [ __ ] nutshell whether you like
it or not [ __ ] what wait what do
you got to tell me nothing it it is
crazy it's uh
i think what it is is
no one really has any real conversations
anymore and then at work
if everyone's talking about this let's
just say the show is the big bang theory
if everyone was talking about that and
then you're the one [ __ ] who doesn't
like it then you have nothing to talk
about them with so that's why i think a
lot of people watch
shows like that just to fit in and have
something to talk about oh jesus [ __ ]
christ you gotta have your soul at the
end of the [ __ ] day
how are you not gonna have your [ __ ]
soul
i never understood that i never [ __ ]
understood how you wanted to be a part
of something
just to be cool
you know i smoke [ __ ] pot i've been
smoking pot now am i proud of it no but
that just goes to show you when i
[ __ ] started smoking pot of 14 i
didn't do it to be cool i did it because
i needed the [ __ ] help i needed i'm
an insecure [ __ ] what are you gonna do
but i know that going in i don't smoke
pop you've never seen a t-shirt on me
with a leaf have you have you ever seen
me with a high times or
420 you ever seen me [ __ ] do that can
you show them your tattoos
i'm gonna put a tattoo of a [ __ ] pop
plant on me get the [ __ ] out of here get
the [ __ ] out of here what's wrong with
these [ __ ] people you don't see high
times on my wall do you you don't see
your shirt with huh it's
get the [ __ ] i lived on i didn't hear
about 4 20 so i moved to l.a did you
know that really i thought 420 was every
minute of the [ __ ] day you [ __ ]
morons
it's like 20. it's not 20. but meanwhile
your wife is sucking somebody else's
dick but you're worried about 420 you
[ __ ] morons
[ __ ] momos
look at me with a pop plant on my shirt
so people know i smoke [ __ ] pot
what's the matter with you
high times i never bought a [ __ ] high
times i didn't know what high times was
so somebody [ __ ] sent me an email
years ago write an article whatever for
about the first time you smoked high
times a poster of a [ __ ] bud i smoked
that [ __ ] bud you gonna put a poster
up a reefer on your [ __ ] wall like
you ten the [ __ ] is wrong with people
the [ __ ] is wrong with people have your
own [ __ ] identity don't surround your
identity because reefer or what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you [ __ ] momos then you
wonder why you get bullied while your
kids get bullied because you're [ __ ]
momo
what what what lee
i love it i just can't wait until some
some poor guy walks up tonight with a
hot with a weed t-shirt
i smoke weed look at me get the [ __ ] out
of my face i smoke weed at seven in the
morning over here puffing [ __ ]
gorilla biscuits look at the old podcast
we'd smoke [ __ ] three joints me and
lee from six to [ __ ] eight o'clock
meanwhile you got a shirt i'm going to
the pot convention this week what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you pot convention
anyway
it's a beautiful day to be alive go out
there you got dreams go [ __ ] do them
nobody's gonna hand you dick in this
[ __ ] life wash your [ __ ] salute the
flag do what you need to do you're a
[ __ ] american get up stop your
[ __ ] whining and stop being a [ __ ]
follower of your [ __ ] life okay it's
your [ __ ] life you're gonna be a
follower like dave caress get the [ __ ]
out of here nobody controls you
[ __ ] you control yourself tell
all these [ __ ] to suck your
dick have a beautiful day the church of
what's happening now [ __ ] now
that the show's over the show ain't over
we're just over for now
now that the child's taking a quick
break don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razors sent to your door every month for
for a fraction of what you made to
retail you started it
because
i'm trying to i'm trying to read this
here
uh now go to dogshaperclub.com
forward slash church or just go to joey
diaz.net and click on the dollar shave
club banner the show is also sponsored
by naturebox.com order great tasting
healthy snacks at 50 off snack smarter
in the new year with healthy and
delicious treats like everything bagel
chips and baked sweet sweet potato fries
support this podcast and get 50 off for
your first order go to naturebox.com
promo code joey naturebox.com promo code
joey and again to nailed itlife.com go
there for the premier vapor pen on the
market mention joe diaz and get 20 20
off have a great week [ __ ] don't
let nobody kid you don't be a sheep
there you go
one of the greatest stories ever [ __ ]
told the rooster alison change
one of my all-time favorites when i hear
this i want to get a bayonet and stab
you right in the [ __ ] eyeball
[ __ ] them
here comes the [ __ ] rooster
[ __ ] just the bayonet you don't wanna
like you have to put that on a gun a
bayonet a [ __ ] axe
oh [ __ ]
listen to this [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] brilliance on a
wednesday morning we're gonna get this
broken down like this huh
you can hear the heroine in this the
[ __ ] pain
he just took the needle out of his
[ __ ] arm he's ready to rock you
understand me he washed his mouth
he took a sip from his [ __ ] water
and it's over
what
ain't find a way to kill me yet are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is [ __ ] tremendous i get
goosebumps i want to [ __ ] just get up
and go to an audition and throw the
[ __ ] out the window
oh [ __ ]
laughing kids what
kick that [ __ ] lee
i